こんにちははじめしたそうです今この動画を見ている人間の中で line を使って
いない物を言いますか
まあ済ませの方もてない人は使ってないと思うんですけどスマホ持ってる方はほっ今は
100%ランクって言うからですよほぼ役はけどラフ月ラインというものを使って
るってことを言い頃ラインさんっても使ってると思うんですけどもあって co2
ツイーン
バッハ
絶対に笑ってしまう line スタンプというもの
こんにちははじめせずので皆さんいろんな a さんと思っていると思うんですけども
僕 line スタンプめっちゃ区と買う人間なんですよ今何個持ってるってなのだ
107個ですね銀座持てるスタンドは107戸ありますさんが逃げないぐっさんと見た
時に僕は見つけてしまいました絶対に笑ってしまうスターン
これはかでお礼がかもしれないんですけどこのスタンプ柄と絶対笑っちゃうんですよ
ちょちょっと紹介しますいきますよこちらのスタッフです
間違えたこちらの参拝してきます
なんでそうなるやいきます
[音楽]
ん
ぷっ
これマジでおもろい
[音楽]
あのー
バーッ
amaran
誰
[音楽]
静かにしてくださいというあのああ
で避ける断末魔五反田やるんですけどもこれが本当にすごいをなる機能ようなが
いろんな人に聞かせてみたんですけどもほぼ100%の確率で笑まぁ普通女の子って
叫ぶと決めたら
ん
みたいなちょっと可愛い声で叫ぶと思うんですけどものスタッフに関してはこれが
初めて
ran
たみたいなおなか女性らしさを突破だった女性だしたといいますか可愛い子ぶってない
んですよ
もう心から断末魔と言いますか本当になんだその切手にさらされた都政の直後いって
いうのがちょっとあまりに推薦すぎで笑ってしまうというかちょっと僕も何言ってるか
よくわかんない
なにいってれかわかんないんですけどとりあえず君なんか超えたスタンプが彼を見てる
かわかんないですけど
笑っちゃうんですよねー
ダラーっという意味で言っず僕の身内の人たちに聞かせたらほぼ100%笑ってるん
ですけども
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
これが一般的にみんなはれた動画っていうのはちょっとわかんないんでちょっと外出て
継承してみようと思いますちょっと外に行ってきますよ海中わけで絆愛ちゃんの弾幕の
スタッフ全員キャップパッド卵です
ちょっと検証していきたいとおもいます
4調べると続きますけどね
goo
wh
he
ええええええ
me
すごい声
ん
me
dea
car
ana あああっ